product not yet rated
[Music]
the killcam is a key part of sniper
elite we introduced it in the first game
as a way to track the bullet in slow
motion from the players gun all the way
to their targets for Sniper Elite v2 we
introduced a whole new level of detail
to it where we actually track the bullet
through their targets in x-ray and
watching as it's smashed bones that it
came in contact with and for Sniper
Elite 3 we want to take it a step
further to really take advantage of the
power of the new consoles and what we
can do on PC
so the x-ray killcam is triggered if the
play gets really good score and that's
based on whether the enemy's moving the
range of the shop and also the area that
the player's aiming for on that target
so within the sniper elite franchise the
killcam really gives us a chance to
experiment a bit more with the sound
while the rest of the game stays
relatively realistic we took the sounds
of cars and airplanes and other
high-speed vehicles laid them on top of
each other stretch them out play to the
pitch really kind of conveyed that like
feeling of speed and the fact that you
were traveling with that bullet
the killcam is kind of like think of it
as layers of an onion and you're peeling
notes away and x-ray is all about the
bullet traveling through on the - there
were three layers there was the outer
skin of the character there were the
bones and then there was the the actual
organs inside that we've added in there
for two layers to that now there's a
full muscle tissue layer and also a
circulatory system and the AE layers
that were there have been
comprehensively reworked so there's a
difference with when the bullet hits the
bone over the killcams we had in v2
there we had sort of predefined areas
where the bone could snap because we had
to set it up all beforehand but now the
bone can actually fracture dynamically
so the fracture will occur in the bone
at the exact point of being impacted
with the bullet we now actually have 3d
mesh particles as well so there are
blobs of blood which will which will
come out which again instead of just
being little 2d images which are laid
onto the screen these are actually
three-dimensional give more shape so the
whole thing that just comes together to
give you a greater sense of the bone
shattering and a more realistic one of
the key reasons for going into all that
detail is to illustrate why people were
so frightened of snipers in world war ii
or indeed in any conflicts the damage
done by a sniper bullet is considerable
and so we're not flinching away from
that and we're showing to the player
what it is that they are doing playing
as Carl Faber and himself the elite
sniper why the enemy is so frightened of
him
so obviously the money shot the killcam
is that final bullet impact we really
wanted to get across that kind of
breaking of bones and the splitting of
organs and that tearing of muscle and
sinew so we took a little trip down our
local grocers and for all manners of
fruit and veg and spent a few days
snapping them and twisting them breaking
them squishing them between our hands to
get the scroll Chi and cracking noises
that we needed for all of the bones and
organs
in addition to the the extra detail
we've added into the the human targets
for the killcam we're also this time
around introducing vehicle kill cams so
some of the vehicle adversaries you come
across in the game i half-tracks and
trucks and tanks will we're actually
showing those in intricate detail as the
bullet passes into them and you take
them out with a well-placed shot
we're really pleased with the way
everything is coming together and we're
looking forward to showing you more of
what we've been talking about in the
run-up to the release of the game
[Music]